do you realize to all of the women who
are out there that are concerned about
lifting weights because they're going to
get too bulky do you know how hard I've
worked to try and desperately become
bulky for 15 years I think it's
dissipating a lot now but there was for
a long time this fear that do a couple
of bicep curls and you're going to look
like the Incredible Hulk it's like me
and my friends have really really prayed
for that to happen forever from a
longevity standpoint we know that
maintaining healthy nerve to muscle
function neuromuscular Junctions is one
of the things that resistance exercise
does and it's highly correlated with
cognitive function into older age
resistance training has an interesting
property that I haven't heard discussed
before that pertains to men and women
who do it which is unlike cardiovascular
training during a resistance training
bout because of the blood flow to the
muscle the so-called pump you get a
little window into what the potential
progress would look like that pump
dissipates post-workout and then if if
you allow sufficient rest and nutrition
Etc you'll get a hypertrophy response
and so I would say for anyone who's
worried about getting too big unless
your pump is bigger than you want to be
you're not going to get that